can you believe he said that
that's rude i'm his wife are you don't
talking
no i'm not and i said once say i'm an
american
what landed the fray
and home of the brave yes
let's keep it going angela people think
i'm crazy the way i treat you
[ __ ] they don't know how you are it
might not look like it right now but
michael finally found some courage and
stood his ground with angela
i say you and everybody knows i'm a
cusser you tell me
you [ __ ] because you give a zombie to
him surprisingly this time around
he didn't back down no
no yourself this time i'm not letting
angela win
yes we will get into this new man that
we are seeing
in just a few plus my relationship with
my mom now
it's complicated aswell opens up about
his tense relationship with his mom and
his sister
aka good old tammy my relationship with
tammy will not really go along we never
talk
after the tarot but to be honest all i
want to know right now
is when is this gonna happen she doesn't
want to baby she doesn't want to be in
here
huh can we just get to the moment
already no we don't like you anymore
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
as you can see i am back in the studio
and after skipping a week happily ever
after is back with a new episode
wow shake that booty judy you know
i didn't think a week would cause me to
miss all of this craziness
but then i heard andre's voice
[Music]
and for the first time ever that voice
right there
brought up some good feelings i don't
know where elia dude
are you done talking no i'm not all
right
let's get into michael finally standing
up to angela
a few days ago me and michael had a huge
fight and we broke up
and we haven't spoke since to give you
the full gist of how
everything went down let's start from
the beginning
what are you doing before the fight
angelo was walking around in one of her
moods
because michael upsets me she's been
cleaning the house
for days which is how you know she's mad
i do this four or five times a day skyla
lately lately hell all of this comes
after she went to talk to her lawyer
about divorcing michael
because of the way he's been treating
her during and following her weight loss
surgeries
he's blowing on my phone can you please
call him nope
after their quote-unquote breakup angela
blocks him pretty much
everywhere so her daughter skyla
had to deal with the repercussions he's
calling me again
please talk to him here i ain't got time
i'm cleaning
i'm not your marriage counselor i'm not
a marriage counselor is what they need
after she played hard to get for a while
angela
eventually called michael you blocked me
out everywhere you block me on you
what's up you block me on facebook who
does that
who does that why not blocked you when i
was healing you went
with
did you talk to your sister like that no
you say sure
sure sure are you done talking no i'm
not
and i said i want to say i'm an american
that is the most gangster way i've ever
heard someone say i'm an american
i mean talk about american pride and i'm
proud to be
an american where at least i know i'm
free
i'm an american michael went on to say
that he doesn't know if he and angela
will reconcile at all
if we can communicate out we will be
together
michael before then you could have
called me you didn't call for
nine weeks nine weeks damn michael
that's a long time we didn't know that
angela proceeded to basically tell on
him
she said that we might think she's crazy
for the way she treats him
but we don't know how he really is i say
you and everybody knows i'm a curser you
tell me you back
you tell me you [ __ ] because you give a
zombie
oh look at michael with a nonchalant
clap because you give us
you can tell he is tired he's over it
and to be honest there is no need to
point the finger here because
it's all dysfunctional let me tell you
you ain't telling me nothing put that
finger down put that
finger down it's not okay for either one
of them to be talking to each other like
that
so angela's saying that michael does it
too it just
makes our situation sound even worse did
you talk to your
sister like that you know if you take
out all the explicit words
close your eyes and tweak their voices
this back and forth
sounds like two kids arguing on the
playground
especially this moment right here
because i deserve it
if my daddy was alive he would have sat
here and waited to come over here and he
would have hand slapped you right in
your mouth
and slapped me my dad would have beat
your ass
you can't even beat no one's ass is that
funny michael thought that was real
funny
this seriously took me back to my
childhood i can hear it now
my daddy will come beat you up nah uh
you don't even know how to fight
yes i do obviously i had no business
hanging out on that playground but
anyway you know i wouldn't see lou
because i really want a divorce
when angela brought up the fact that she
went to a lawyer to discuss getting a
divorce
i was expecting michael to fold like he
usually does
but that didn't happen i was hoping she
would listen to me
but she starts yelling at me and i'm so
mad about it
for the entire relationship i let her
win
i'm just sick of it and this time i'm
not letting angela win
why does somebody have to win isn't love
about compromise
or does that just not apply here well
michael might not be letting angela walk
away as the top dog this time
but he did give her a round of applause
maybe i'll find the man that'll take
care of me instead of me taking care of
them
no yourself i ain't talking to him guess
what he doesn't mean anymore
he's mad at me because something he's
done
what should michael have done oh good
question producer
he should have got my mind off of the
argument if you wanted the argument to
end
somebody's got to give in and i'm not
because i am not going to take no man
i'm not i don't have to live like this 7
000 miles away and be neglected
i don't i do not
and i won't oh her feelings are hurt
the truth is we've all dealt with issues
when it comes to how we handle
relationships
everyone comes with their own baggage
right
angela she tends to use aggression as a
protective mechanism
playing bully so she won't get hurt oh
shut up
over and over my wish for her is that
she becomes okay with
being vulnerable because to really be
loved that's what you have to be
vulnerable i wish he would say
one time i'm sorry and he's just not
doing it
if she would just communicate her
feelings to michael like that
instead of like this side of the bed
inside of a bed
it would make a world of difference
these nasty fights that they're having
are happening
so much that they're starting to blend
together
i feel like i sound like a broken record
when i talk about
angela cursing out michael every week
every week it's something
at least this time around he stood his
ground though
yourself all right well speaking of
fights
i want people to know we are getting
more context on what this upcoming fight
between kalani and asuelu's family
is going to be about during this episode
i swallow revealed that he hasn't spoken
to his sister tammy
since last season's tell-all they need
to get divorced
and although he speaks to his mom their
relationship is still awkward
just give me money that's all i want all
this comes after asuelu's mom
asked him and kalani to give her money
as part of a samoa tradition
and although kalani made it clear that
they didn't have the money to give
if he's giving all this money that he
doesn't have then he's going to be poor
aswell's mom and sister tammy wouldn't
take no for an answer
i'm sorry clary i don't care about the
kids tammy even went as far as trying to
fight kalani which
was a hot mess it's a well yeah
fast forward to now aswell is talking to
his mom
and she says that she wants to come
visit the kids because she's planning to
go back to samoa
yes she wants to visit the same kid she
says she didn't care about
she also wants to bring tammy i am very
worried if tammy is going to come down
here and
mess everything's up because i have no
idea if
kalani or kalani's family can go along
with tammy
so considering that you would think he
would ask kalani before telling his mom
yes
but of course he didn't very important
for me to see my mom before she leave
because i know
she's really old but i'm very concerned
that
tammy will come down here and bring a
bad attitude
i don't know how my wife you feel when i
told her my mom's and time will come
down here
hopefully she's not upset please
she's definitely gonna be upset in
addition to that
he talks to his mom about how he wants
more kids
because having a big family is part of
his culture the big family is just
strong fam
but because kalani is thinking with her
head and why would we have another kid
when we don't even have our own place
that makes no sense
that's not something she wants right now
nevertheless
when oswell's family comes to visit it
sounds like that's what they're going to
be pushing for she doesn't want to baby
well next week aswell ruins the
christmas cheer
by telling kalani and her family that he
invited drama to the house
my mom she really wants to see us so
time is gonna drive her down here last
time her and i talked didn't go very
well so
she threatened to beat up my sister when
she sees her so
this isn't really how i pictured
christmas or the holiday season
this is gonna be really bad yeah it
looks like it
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
you